so it looks like Ezra Miller is going to
get a plea deal so they got uh in
trouble well a number of ways last year
but they were charged with burglary in
Vermont which could have carried up to a
10-year sentence and it looks like they
are going to plead down to trespass
which is not nearly as big a deal I've
been trying to track down what's gone on
with some of the other legal trouble
that they were into I can't really find
anything I don't know if it's just been
quietly dropped or what but regardless
at this point and given that it has been
acknowledged that Miller is seeking uh
mental health care this really is the
best case scenario for Warner Brothers
Discovery because I've said before the
flash was too expensive for them to just
drop as a movie and actually the word is
that it tested so well they might even
want to keep Ezra Miller on until later
I'm dubious about that notion because
they've dropped far more popular people
that fans were really excited about
keeping Miller that just seems like a
bad move but I guess we'll see